all right so the game i want to share
today
is a game that i played on an airplane
i took a direct flight from chicago to
dubai it was a 13 hour flight actually
on route to photograph at the fide world
championship
and on the plane i discovered
that uh in the the built-in
entertainment system in front of my seat
there is a game called kasparov
chessmate in which you can play an ai
version
of the one and only gary kasparov now it
allowed me to select the difficulty
of my opponent but it only allowed me to
select up until 2300
so i didn't really get the the real deal
of the the 2850 gary kasparov but 2300
especially for an ai it's still uh still
a level that can be difficult to beat
and
we went ahead and started a game
and as we're gonna see the game features
a staffer gambit but it also just
features a really really fun
tactical attacking sequence that i think
all of you are going to enjoy
so before we get into the game i do want
to give a big thanks to the sponsor
of today's video which is audible
now when i'm on a plane and i'm not
defeating kasparov bot uh with the
staffer gambit i do really enjoy
listening to audiobooks and audible is
my go-to platform to do that they have a
huge variety of genres from comedy to
non-fiction to fiction sci-fi romance
whatever you're into any sort of spoken
word entertainment you can find on
audible and let me give a sneak peek
into my personal audio library and just
share
some of the titles that i've been
enjoying in recent weeks and months and
one audiobook that i do want to
highlight
is a new release is chess queens by
jennifer shahadi
and this is an audiobook that i am in
the process of listening to and i've
really really been enjoying so far
it highlights some of the triumphs and
struggles of women in chess
and talks a lot about some of the
notable inspiration and success stories
including the polgar sisters and pia
kremling
and some of the early pioneers in chess
like sonia graf and vera manchuk and i
do have to say jennifer shotty does an
amazing job narrating the book and
providing some really nice insights that
i would not have been aware of otherwise
so if you would like to try out audible
for free and listen to any audiobook of
your choice click the link in the
description audible.com iamrosen or text
i am rosen to 500 500. you can listen to
chess queens or any other audiobook of
your choice and i really hope audible
brings as much value to you as it's
brought to me and with that let's get
back to the chess
so the game started gary played e4 and
even though this is a bot representation
of gary's kasparov
i'll just be referring to him as gary
and i responded with e5 it was my goal
to enter a staffer gambit and to my
dismay
gary did not take the pawn on e5
but rather played knight to c3 and i was
a little bit disappointed here but i
really insisted that we enter a stafford
and if you do want a stafford from this
position the move to play is bishop to
c5
and this is considered a dubious move
because you are
you are counting upon but its only way
to attempt to transpose back into the
stafford
the alternative is knight to c6 which is
a bit more symmetrical can lead to
either a four night scotch or four
knight's main line
but
after i played bishop c5 we did
transpose back into the staffer gambit
after takes
and knight to c6
and i actually had this position against
magnus carlsen real life magnus carlson
in a titled arena
over a year ago and magnus played knight
f3 here which is a very sensible move
and
the game continued d5 takes takes and
then d4
and after bishop b4 bishop d2
uh the game continued i'll leave a link
to that video if you want to check it
out but i will say that magnus
did handle the the opening and the
middle game quite well
so uh we did not enter this line in this
game uh but rather after knight c6
gary took on c6 and i took back with the
pawn it's as if we just entered a
staffer normally it's usually black who
had just played bishop c5 here but this
is a direct transposition
and for the staffer gambit aficionados
out there you'll know the the main move
for white and the supposed refutation
is pawn to
h3 which is recommended by
a lot of other like coaches and chess
youtubers as just a safe way to meet the
stafford because it prevents knight g4
and
i'll admit that yeah black does have
some issues in this line
there's been a number of moves i tried
here between h5 and g5 and b5
and there's still room to try and muddy
the waters
but white is objectively doing quite
well here if they don't fall into
any trickiness
but instead of playing h3 in this game
we see bishop to e2 which is also a very
sensible move but this move is prone to
some really nasty traps
and the move i play here is pawn h5 now
the alternative instead of h5 is to play
queen to d4
but as we'll see sometimes these lines
transpose
and the point of pawn h5 is to support
the g4 square
to basically prepare knight g4 next and
get multiple pieces attacking on the
king side
now from here i will say
the best move for white is to play pawn
d3
which was not played in this game but
the point upon d3 is to quickly develop
the bishop and if i play knight g4 i can
take take and play bishop e3
and this is a position i've had
countless times before
actually i'm checking my stats here on
the chess i've had this position 25
times
and
i've scored pretty well even here
despite the fact the engine will say
white's a bit better after the move
queen to d6 black has some kind of
nagging pressure against the pawn on h2
and there's potential tactics where if
white plays g3 black can take and win
back the pawn and go into some end game
but
i don't want to go on too much of a
tangent because
instead of d3 white in this game
castled kingside
which is a really risky move and uh
sometimes you'll see this in engine
chess is engine will play a move without
fear
but
sometimes it's just a matter of not
calculating far enough and i'm pretty
sure that's what happened to my my ai
opponent in this game
is
white took a little bit too many risks
and then just reached a point of no
return
so i continue here knight g4
threatening the very deadly queen to h4
to attack both f2 and h2 and white plays
a very logical move upon h3 just trying
to kick away the knights
and make it so queen h4 isn't as
powerful
but in this position
uh black has a really really nice move
that i'll just go ahead and show
is queen to d4
and what this does is it puts a third
attacker on f2
and this is also still opening
preparation for my side
i usually get this position from a
slightly different move order it usually
happens if white plays h3 first
then after queen d4 castling knight g4
this would be a direct transposition
and if we take a look at what's going on
here there's not too many ways for white
to effectively defend f2
and
in this game gary took on g4 which
at first it looks like white's surviving
but if we calculate a little bit further
you'll see that white's just completely
completely toast
now the best move according to the
engine is bishop takes g4
after which black just has a raging
attack with uh now the pawn the bishop
the rook
all aimed towards h3
combined with this battery and engine
gives a decisive advantage black in this
position
so what happened the game is after takes
takes
bishop takes g4 was played
now i do want to show a really cool line
which has probably been featured in some
of my other staffer gambit videos but
it's a line that just never gets old
and
it involves another piece sacrifice from
black after white plays probably what's
the best try is g3 attempting to play
king g2 and rook h1
black just has a really beautiful
sequence after queen e5
king g2
this is black to move and find the only
winning move
now i guess i gave some sort of clue
that it does involve another piece
sacrifice
but if you haven't seen this before and
you don't see it already feel free to
pause the video and find the absolutely
crushing move for black in this position
and the dog is barking maybe the dog
finds it too
so congratulations if you found the move
bishop takes f2
uh just blowing up the entire king side
for white
and the point is if rook takes f2 and
there's queen h5 and there's just no
stopping the the threats along each file
black is threatening queen e3 king g1
and queen h1 mate
and if king digs f2
this leads to a really funny line
rook h2 check king e3
queen digs g3 king d4 and then bishop to
e6
and
even though black is down two pieces
black is ready to castle queenside with
check
and uh it's usually not a good sign when
your king is the most developed piece
in the opening and queens are still on
the board
so i was a little bit uh disappointed
this position did not occur
but what we're going to see is also
pretty savage
going back
uh pawn takes pawn pawn takes pawn and
bishop takes pawn was played
and here there's a very
simple and nice move for black
queen to e5 a very simply threatening
checkmate in one and there's very very
few ways for white to defend
against a threat
and already
it seemed like the computer was just
trying to delay the game as much as
possible
bishop h3 was played
i happily took the bishop
and then after pawn d4 i took the pawn
now we see queen to f3
so white trying to put up a little bit
of resistance
but after a nice move bishop to g4
i can say oh no my bishop
and if white takes it then there's
checkmate on h2
so bishop g4 has a nice threat of
hitting the queen and also threatening
mate so for that reason queen f4 is
played
but this doesn't slow down my initiative
i simply slide over to h file queen h5
threatening mate on h1
and the only move
to
uh to keep the game going for a bit
longer is to play
the very desperate
queen to h6
obstructing my queen rook battery this
is a very telltale sign of playing an
engine where it just chucks pieces
trying to prolong the mate for as long
as possible so if we zoom forward here
i took the queen
and after rook to e1
i now
leverage the half open g file
and for some reason the rook moved back
to f1
and i think robot gary was beginning to
tilt a little bit
and just show its emotions by moving its
rook back and forth
i went in for bishop to f3 and i really
thought i was gonna be meeting on the
very next move
but white prolonged the game for a
couple more moves after bishop g5
i took the bishop
rookie one i took the pawn king f1
and queen to h1 checkmate
i defeated
kaspar of bot in just 20 moves with
black
and with the staffer gabbit it was a
very feel-good game
now for those of you who might be
doubting that this game actually
happened
i do have video proof
which i think i'll just speed up and
share above my head
so if you want to watch at like 25 speed
you can see the game unfold
but i hope you enjoyed this game
and i hope this gives inspiration for uh
for taking down
not only robot grand masters but maybe
even real grandmasters too
so with that let me know if you have any
questions leave them in the comments and
i'll see you in the next video